[music]
well, dear friends, we
apologize for technical reasons beyond our
control, we had
some kind of failure there, in general, we missed the
end of the 7th round, the players are already preparing
start round 8 let's quickly
look at the table of results what
happened there in the seventh round
unfortunately but maybe at the end of the day
we will still be able to show the
missed lost game before
lesas fabiano caruana drew you and the leader
obviously does not change Mamedyarov
lost to nakamura before  your logrov
lost to sergey karjakin so
here we have shown a quick table before they
showed a fast table for some reason removed
Aronian wins they look like steps are again
compared and wounded by your logrov and
will play in the next round between
themselves here please the results before
Aronian and yours  heads of loggers 15
each 18 points from the forest and
sergey karyakin is coming close 14 and a half
most likely it will fight well, either
nakamura or grischuk should add very strongly,
then these are those who will compete
for the first three places in fact before for the
pedestal
in the tournament in lebanon, I remind you tomorrow on the
last day of the games will start two
hours earlier, and so the 8th round, by the
way, can  also to note that he escaped from the forest with
difficulty against the crown in the previous
round, that is, he passed through a lost
position, well, everything there, already in seconds, everything
managed to luckily rebound
to a draw show us yes, here there
in if you look at the dior pines, we will
probably be closer to the park  closest
pursuers yes on the desk of the closest
pursuers for the game your ate gravel
and Aronian and I will now explain why
because for one of them, perhaps, the
struggle can be very complicated, yes,
that is, now to get, say, 800
makes another
nothing so colorless, but here some-  then the
result, as soon as there is some
result here, the date of the loser is clear that
we will be very, very hard to catch up
like this  here is the reti debut here unexpectedly for the first
time of a
variant of which I know at least something and
so here is castling and 646 cd
cd and here is such a queen b3 hotfix
b6
black is a little bit similar but so
very reliable for 2-3 well, here it’s
interesting that white is trying to somehow 1
put on b5 there to capture the square up to 40
to pretend that this bishop on their 5 is not
so good here, yes, that is, white
she doesn’t plan to play 4 for quite a
long time already there is a classic game where
Capablanca developed the beginning of the bishop on f5
and then retreated found he had to go and
and 6 as if nothing had happened so well, here
we actually have other a little bit of
events happening rain black play
flanges 5 allowing for the move not h4 yes, this
was actually such a
crossroads for black and what can be played and the
system 6 to take care of this bishop
so that there is no possibility of a helmet, then
white will play for some 5
knights there, in my opinion on d4  somewhere here f4 even
sometimes here and the messengers 5 conner 4 just
takes away gets the opportunity to take the
bishop 60 with the advantage of two bishops
try to prove yes cubed g6
plays levon no this is maxim sorry this
is just maxim we took White plays
but by the way if  if you kill, you will probably
be able to carry it out somehow and 3d 4d
stabilize the center, then the kill, of course,
will just be seriously more pleasant, yes, it’s
just better for the positions and on the container, and while
Black can at least somehow
be dynamic, maybe even
the knight  well, while the king is playing
up to 7, then it’s still the same and they bet
that it’s just their weakness in them and not so
significantly yes, well, let’s say I’m standing with
doubling for the time being, no one cares at all,
but the pawns b but the king just doesn’t actively
manifest itself when accidentally protected, but you
as if 2 yes not so not until spring
on white really e 3 to 4
probably need to somehow try to put
yes there the bishop on d2
here somewhere fc one bishop f1 is t  what a
very very long story, but if
somehow all this succeeds, he goes to 4, by the
way, but what’s going on
there, and White played from 0 to 20
before such an entry of words to 2 started, and now
Black played the knight d4 for all the same  the area
pleases me with any position for some kind of
dynamics, what is so incomprehensible no
matter how calm it is initially, by the way,
even in these of the shelves, as we noted earlier, the
water and the calm ones
are a little dry, like positions sometimes even seem
so not particularly in style, but it
hurts  play calm Spanish girls, yes, but
here he manages to turn them around by squeezing them out,
and some interesting
positions arise, so I’m on t1 and that
you can of course put b3, let’s say
forbid the move d4 he has sony
and he played one,
well, why they weren’t played  I was going not to
remove the elephants 4 left the moon at 4 there is no
word, still it’s a pity worthy 4 the window
can’t be behind this elephant I would understand
5 and maybe while it’s at 404 I
didn’t really like something and we’ll be protecting
again  it seemed at the window to take offhand on
bo2 and until the morning gave db25 service 2 yes and
there is a rook b1 if again
some kind of move I have 4 for such
underground levon yes because it’s a
little bit whether he blundered or we
slip the account yes  because of course the
chests go like a river 5
yes they get along with you ribbons the moon is up to 4 protected
yes therefore it leaves as much as htc 8 to logically c8
that is, but here it can and even
beat in the dacha love for them
characterizes Armenian sponsored and
yes yes  yes, it turns out like this, well, that is, all the
same, no, in fact, the word leggings 2 is
stupid, but if they took
it, it looks like they need 4 with a bottle, it will also make
some weaknesses of creation, even white on the
topic, maybe yes, it may turn out that the
twist will twist the hour wounded how
then they get along  8 already wants to go to
t2 and kaina three pieces powerfully worth powerfully
worth the knight on b3,
that is, you can 3 just not a coup at all in
the opening, it seems to me that he did so
tamed back yes there the amount may
turn out to be what you dey  really, it’s
just that it’s just necessary to somehow calmly
develop the bishop d2 go well 1 so
little by little they yelled at reale water
and one by one Black already has the
opportunity to make a draw by repeating
moves
tapah
let's hope for dates we somehow do
n't even hope that the game
will continue anyway to confirm that it was not in vain that
we chose it owners 2 plays no
sinbo knight
wait-wait voice and well
I added the time
given to the opponent 20 such cases
it is not clear to whom I jump this benefit, that is
, he still has
more time than he answered a little before the
proverb 2 la grandfather 2 goes well 8
something is quite risk-free for me
correct and 2 rook suits  on s8,
what is the lemon afraid of here is not entirely
clear, but it seems to me that other
posadas have nothing to fear, yes, I washed it, no,
you can even if we say they won’t play
white there  th king f1 here is the horse 3 look
kombat trilogy took it didn’t take it and now
completely cemented the date with never
get along one no then you can even try
gave the kindergarten went well done well
done it’s clear that well,
to use the chances gave the
king f1 to play immediately yes on the
diabetes b2 channel  there is at least servant 5, since
he is 4 not only g4 there is nowhere yet, but knight
3, all the same, this
arrangement with the knight on b3 is so
very unpleasant, yes, he already wants to take
both to b2 and three stages of sodium on wap
clothes,
but you can  just on cs2 and go there, yes,
you can enjoy life in what positions
yes, well, here already I don’t know white already
think about e4 somewhere you will run into the tip with a
drummer 4 but I don’t know how to win
him her husband 4 played me 4 played aka
4  of course, it asks for a move, but maybe it’s
without any special threats, the canon of the country, it
seems to me, in a pinch, black can
go d4
if not 5 is just a knight, but this is
pretty yes, yes, five and five kunas up to 5
took, that is, a bunch of doubles  pawns
opposition is better by the
way, these are novice players very often
they ask me they just don’t understand
how it’s so with double pawns they don’t
consider it as always a weakness but that
pawns are sometimes controlled by the central
field yes that is sometimes important for a long time now
look here everything goes to that and on  in
fact, there is still how it is again, except for e4
to 4, it was played on e5, except for county 5, the
same move is probably possible, that is, here, well,
you still need to count bishops, but 3 well, judging
by how your kilogram played,
judging by how the elephant played the logr
and in 3 he was such an ode-kun 4 he was afraid of
what he was thinking 12 own b2 and like this
either he doesn’t play here I hit 2 basements I
would alone we can even beat the exchanges by
3 apparently yes, and the
black pieces will stand a little awkwardly  before exchanging for 3 and
iceland din a from the moons to 1 has time because
there is e5 probably again don’t know there’s
nothing good schoolgirls are not
smart 525 they took to b6 they took the rook to d3 so we
gradually gradually
simplified  3 points
will go to me, although it’s possible to get water from
Arina on e4, the whole bishop hangs on e4
, that is, you need to move, then you need to make a move with tempo,
block b3, then  you can
play
ana beatriz try to exchange la dee
da of
course the rook b3 moves-walks aronian gave
db-3 to hold up to 6 check the king where there
is m probably yes or maybe take courage on their
feet can be expected maybe
a nation yes and reached 4  we’ll take it on
and 408 like this, so as not to fall
somewhere under the closet, there’s objectively
nothing to talk about here, yes, there’s a won
position, a won position to the left
on Aronian, and so, out of the blue, he
rolls his perhaps
closest competitor inconspicuously, yes, that is, the leader
of the tournament, we know that you are from the forests of which
there are much more points, but nostril to
nostril, what is called your
Logr and Aronian, then if Logran is at all, this
will be the second defeat in a row, by the way
it’s necessary,
and so, the inhabitants of Odessa already before this
game of ours were in general, so he lost,
lost to Karyakin, and now he is on the verge of
defeat with a lemon and Ryan,
so I’ll give out a little bit to update the
situation  of the king, everything is in order for
black, that is, the present
chance for some tricks is tactical,
but here it should be noted that the tricks are
just more often in the country owning horses,
as if, in general, hopes these
headphones are 5, I don’t know, I need to put them 5
more  like who watched the rivers
fabric and you can even crawl somewhere 5 somewhere
even 4 yes, that would be quite
nice powerful not half a wall powerful a matter of
taste neatly unless full full
so to speak completely consolidate
and don’t rush probably even with the
movement of a pawn b a  first, as much as
possible, strengthen it as much as possible, strengthen the position
so that b5 is about to knock out support from the
end of the episode, I don’t immediately want to
gradually
shorten  le there m this is exactly
what levon does let candy 2 play to
exchange one of the bishops but yes
there is no sun there 5 men he played it looks like
he played g2a played played pnd 277
so wait yes i didn't understand the sun 5
that it was a yawn it looked like  low tide on
Aronian sun 5 yes it looks like it was you
know it's just like it's on foot
although baby siphon it's just just a
yawn of a pawn it's unbelievable
just now we announced that everything is in order everything
Aronian should win here without
problems and now he relaxed and  now I’m
far from sure that it’s possible
that he will succeed in this position before, that is,
it’s not the fact that he won in general, well
, something incomprehensible is going on there are two,
so literally b3 yes, but nerves and so
I think nerves are probably already the action of an
elephant and in 3 well  in general, there will be
such a defense one way or another, taking into account over
time, yours is not very
good  rver is a resource, it’s only worth every now and then
that it saved their exercises, because inside
for 2 we have 3 by 200 here
anyway, somehow with a horse there are chances, I would say
that there is, but the lags were exchanged, this is
interesting, yes the rooks were exchanged defended by the
count  doing their own thing being their favorite
thing played them 4 so you know
right now he was reading f40 on him he was one more
pawn she was just forcing I
exchanged another pawn something
wounded that I don’t understand how
Aronian plans to win that one, that is, soloing two on one
what does it look like that
a draw is waiting for us here, even yes, even if
black plays four, white can
stand just a king, even two, and roared
moved the knight to f6,
wakes up the knight, having eaten it like that, but
here they will probably jump for
quite a long time, yes, I probably think that
you can predict a draw and see
what else is going on grischuk lost
against whom
I even run out of time finished
a draw here they have steps and vichy
ananda mamedyarov won in le  su
yes guys what happens mamedyarov
defeated vasilisa
from the forest knows how to play evidence
that you are also from the forest a man of the mamedyarovs
defeat you the forest what ended the
tour guide we continue the game of pockets
against
karyakin  who is better for
blitz, of course, karjakin has a better position of
karjakin of the best position zombies quality,
but there is an absolutely open king for white,
everyone objectively wins here
already  now look the king is cut off
there and the flank before the fall of the flag of hell there is a
delay in time there is no longer a flag to
know and from the old days there was an
expression when there was a mechanical
watch winner  defeat so let's
strike a balance what we have in common
is
victory  No Karjakin looks like he is
wedged into the division 2 yes it looks like in the
hospitals division 2 by the way, already 33 people
are two and a half points behind sleep,
even if they reduced it to reduce the
lead a little bit in from the forest, it is defeated, I think
that we have time to show this game
and  a bunch of draw weights a draw with anand of your
logr to the shed and we know
that the position of the Aronians was absolutely won, she was
tired apparently tired our participants are a
little bit so very whose this student is
2 yes sorry because for k murada
only mura defeated nakamura defeated
grischuk and I suggest to look  so,
probably, grischuk for nakamura’s desk and, of
course, for the game how we defeated the leader, yes,
we’ll probably start by watching the game of
Vasilis’ mamedyarovs,
we’ll start by watching the park of menhirs if it’s a
dream and such an absolutely unpretentious opening
such a knight b on d2
bishop and in 5 on 4 6 and there was such
option against slavs [ __ ] b2 and i'm
not far from sure strain bishop and in 5 here is the
correct move queen b3 health b6 end of
4th something like that they  there they played the bishop
g4 e3 calmly the last four
explanations 2 yes, I’m far from sure that
Estonia has four notes, although maybe
in general it’s possible to go back, that is,
it’s necessary 7
Unfortunately, there is no time to analyze,
they took it, and 3 I’ll take you, which is nice
nice, it’s already nicer of course c5,
as if before 2 cd at the end of 6 sun 3, that is, he
always offers to take 4
shahriyar, but then it’s
impossible to take not up to 4 knight d4 here through  beats a
long gap until the
white knights win long castling
long castling scrapped b4 [ __ ] 2 well, for
now, so to say that everything is fine here,
learning black threads went badly and 535 of
this face and 8-ku need a river of bdsm and who
told me in this position that white has
advantage I would not believe in it black
hour they are seeking a blockade and in my opinion what is
just pleasant mistakes of the accounting agenda are
infected finally again of course d7 mamma
mia rafah starts here to bring pieces
in the direction of the king  before the tricks of the
queen begin 6 exchange for a 6-ku not at five attacked
the same 7 and normally for 6 on and on and on and on
all our models forever about this from
one to them jumped what is called
a c5 so what if a looks like this is also
his  it’s just that today it looks like it’s also a
blunder, that is, here, apparently, the air force of the forest
chose which of the pawns to give up yes, well, I don’t
understand what is possible there if
martens 5 on such a non-dc knight can
play dc5 yes, we give away on this yes,
probably the position is not the best  pleasant, but
somehow with something else, the player c5
sells or is it not just all the sweets,
everyone, look, you can see some kind of
aggravation of the water, we don’t have time to do it, then
finally where do you have time 8 I had
some idea, maybe he plans to
drink  on f2 it doesn’t work,
that is, the king 20 by the way, there was an idea, maybe
another rook goes to f8 another camp,
try to understand 80 f 2 beforehand and
live 8 back the king, let’s say I don’t know the
king d2, and you have to go
back to pick up his knight, well,
that’s also  at least necessary  it’s possible for everyone to
believe that Elodea took it all this bishop
c4 will do win win win but
further on it seems that interest is already being lost
, yes, because some
material advantage is
quite serious enough,
I don’t know how confidently, but
I realized Shahriyar material
advantage, by the
way, knights  then they are bouncy, yes, but somehow you
managed to avoid it, don’t put it under
any fork, and hit it yourself, yes,
here’s how, again, the bishop c2 would be the king,
I think that counting oats is what is called
Mamedyarov in such positions, it’s very,
very difficult, it’s the same  what
wins plus draw plus is equal to the
forest against you
so well what and in the end well here is the end of the
game like this king c7 ours
robbed everyone like sticky la diabetes up to 7 extra
sleep and a couple of pawns to defeat the
mamedyars which confuses the
tournament situation a little bit you by the way  Yes,
very confusing, confusing the tournament
situation, and of course,
Aronian spoiled the tournament situation very much for himself without
winning an absolute  a fiercely won position that
would share all two points would say
only two Chara Aronian a and Ryan and your
thoughts are soda, but Aronian could not win his absolute
position on the position contrary to the gram.
yes, he’s still trying to
prove that he was also not in vain a contender,
but he alternates with victory, that is, in
rapid, and his enemies in the last round
rapido defeated pockets with black, and
now karjakin with black, the revenge was
in blitz in the first round of blitz let me
remind you what else to us  of course,
circle 2 will have to go through so we still
have enough time, let's check what
happened in one more game that is quite
principled, as we noted those
rivals, the eternal nakamura of games,
who, in addition to the actual game of you
themselves, have competitions with a score of 1000 games
or he is a generous party online, yes  there is
it endlessly these duels for a minute before
which there are still on the site the internet part of the
club once its time  it happened and
so here we have and here we had
this newfangled invention this is a very
funny opening variation again against
those who play greenfield this is applicable
in my first time venus will be able iran
itself at the very end 3 to 7 to 6 this
problem here I will find everyone  fist of before the
variant of people playing the variant bustard
that they can’t make the move the c6 knight
can, well, it doesn’t work out very well, yes,
because after the move, the white knight f3
will go the next move up to 4 already a
variant of meters, but it doesn’t work either
you need to go in the groove the boat is flexible but somehow  then
it’s possible by the way on the second move, but 60 cen is
not to everyone’s liking, in general, most
often those who play meters answer up to
76 meters find in the center,
then it follows up to 4 cd and this is such
an absolutely strange development to the queen b4
knight c6 d2
well, again  looks like a beginner's game
actually killed enough such an
understandable concept to play b3 bishop b2 and
castle quickly in the long side
and then roll on the king but by the
way I suspect that  then even such direct
recipes against this variant are not with
Joe until the theory and have not figured it
out yet got through black
White’s position is no worse they don’t believe that
they have an advantage so get a well position but
you don’t want to fight White no worse
make a large margin of safety
develop make sensible moves but
what to get from this bishop h6 well, I christen it
under quite original and in the 4th all
in 5 bishop b2 knight f6
well, that is, such a fairly aggressive
development system up to 3 queens 5f
as if in five kun 20
I like Grischuk in general  and then it’s very clear
mp4
queen d2 lagina c8 some initiative
under developed to a2 a3
and here it took 6 years maybe
this is some unsuccessful moment yes
because no tactics started guarding
and maybe a jump to the skate 4 yes and maybe maybe
to be here is to castle her hairpin
to drag the mouse not 4 move but this is too much and
vodka odd developed 2 yes well there the
king must pass too him the
scythe maybe it was possible to castle that is
to enter the rook from the diagonal dain hunt 3
now it seems to be possible to
access the Internet again, you can’t anyway by 4
and by the way at 30 and don’t forget at 3 0 no one’s
eyes but it seems to me it’s all buzzing
and even so at least the owners of 8 had to
return  on c6 but this is not the
farthest most pleasant but nevertheless 3
0 2 0 the king b1 and in these very
typical before position arises from this
variation that the bishop on b2 of the end is very
very appropriate water
well protects the white king but also the point
structure  it should be noted that black is still
worse, these pawns up to 7
our system does not somehow
move forward nominally this center seems to
climb up that there are two pawns against 0
pawns for black in the center but in fact
they are extras in the center is placed by
white  it’s interesting to let the move serve
m well, someone could wait until some
attempts to attack on the kingside
yes maybe that’s not bad either h2 h3
plays b5 here it’s just emphasized
so culturally yes in the center and
hick  aru nakamura deer I'm already on and 1 in 4
they took they took the knight d4 well, these are the
feelings that it means to play an intermediary
with white everything in the center of everything very much so you
.
nails are driven in, everything has defended
now everything has gone forward the knight fd5 the knight a4 is
not changing and 5 was taken and here
here the truth is that the move is far from
trivial in the center
and what kind of c3 I'm sorry and so you can play
but wait and what is she and maybe
all the same  some problems and the husband
some problems so he
already praises praise hikaro here j5 probably for leaving
22 depend on the acacia there was a change of
scenery because we already
announced nakamura to be inspected
and then at the moment after the queens barely tokugari the
pike is full  the order was, well, complete,
turning, to put it mildly, complete order, but
he actually won, it seems he
won somewhere, by the way,
probably probably even at this moment,
and something there on Federico’s blog from here to the
end 2 some terrible move to the queen in
5 is put  2 it looks like the king
should go to one through f5 yes, but there are versions 4
move can be verdi 4 then well, even there are
exchanges and villains 2 there is too much of
course of course orange version in 2
you can go well, in general, ogre  ohm superiority
was Alexander's pike, in fact, up to
version 6 of the villains, one, I so-so venture to
suggest that there was some kind of creepy
flower once again, and there Grischuk
began to get lost today, gave delphi 8
, honestly, sin begins to
feel like he just started to sculpt
move any queens shooting at e3 there is
about why the far one is already well on the obverse
everything is clear to everyone and I and all
reputable role-playing about them
and yes, by the way, why
before that it was just too much, but I
’m trying to explain that here and even then it’s not
worth coming up to know from such a
computer assessment, because
Alexander probably already had a
few seconds left there, in general, they took
trouble here 4 this  Of course, the batteries, the
battery, they probably took it here, they took it at the end of 5,
it may turn out that this is generally,
even objectively, then the position is so
as good as you are a miracle of some kind  oh so in
black stavlin tied
black bandaged and imagine yes here you have three
seconds per move until in the mode of three seconds
per move forced to play such a position
queen b7
shox I alone through f8 bishop to 4
returns nakamura some checks here does not
allow h5 camera only about  if the
queen is e5 so sorry, here was the move of the
queens and at 5 it's true here was the move of the
queen 5 which of course had to
do something after that, as before,
white still has, I think, the chances of a rebound
and the pieces are not very good, then
on foot  and runs but the king of what steam
needs to go but you can go the king is 8
to mp5 already marten 6 yes you don’t belly can
be white to do nothing but it’s
not so important for us because alexander went
h5 and after the move the knight e6 something here
something got a little bad for him, well,
let's just say that the parade of errors we have is similar to
here, in fact, although
it’s impossible to criticize the players like that either, it’s very
difficult to play a lot of time and I’m sure
that or any of them happened of course when it’s
just  a lot of time and a friend a
pawn of him, this is really strange,
yes, Aronian is just a pawn out of the blue,
in fact, he blundered to what he seriously
spoiled his chance, well, well,
now it ends in the next one,
literally in a couple of minutes the
last round of today's such will begin, but in
fact  today they played a whole blitz
tournament everyone played with everyone yes, that
is, before us, expectations have outgrown
rawhide moore 1 round the first round in this
2 round blitz today can be
considered as one such small
tournament, by the way, at the end after the
last round we will also let you down  results
who is the leader in the overall standings
and who spent the best today spent the
day let's see
what awaits us in the last round what
couples are left already we could
probably calculate them well let's try
now let's slice he will play
against hikaru nakamura
next who  we have sergey karyakin against
shahriyar
mamedyarov aronian caruana anand your ela count
alexander gri  pike to fight with the lowest weight
and by the way I don’t even know what is the most
interesting game for these so far it’s hard to
say yes let’s somehow
let’s wait a couple more minutes now he’s
showing us Mamedyarov against Karjakin
they’ve already sat down at the board
maybe I don’t even know what to us to us
choose to give now the nakamura lawn the
americans can try before we can
try to look at a couple with against
nakamura by the way here and still no at the board
here they appeared then I appeared here
games karyakin mamedyarov again friends
rivals yes well friends to disgrace new
friends before but u barely barely escaped there
more  100 moves to demand the need for
Karyakin to run away for a draw from
Shakhriyar Mamedyarov and on the way
there, of course, it was absolutely lost there, it did
n’t cause tagil, of course, it’s completely
disappointing, first of all, for
himself and his performance is a
hopeless last place, so why
went against nakamura here  that's probably
it we'll see what's the last
minute left  before the start of the game, yes,
but hikaru, of course, after defeating grischuk,
he will try, first of all, he will
definitely try to win, wesley
will try and will try, of course, tomorrow, the
highest possible result, I’m there
something problem, the queen,
mock for hours, everything is in order, everything is in order,
there is a queen’s gambit  - then there
will he try to play fast enough whether he will try to be or they
should even be able to keep up with it,
but it seems to me that he very quickly
knows the people’s husband, we’ll hear it and it looks like they made a
mistake with the choice of the park and now
right here such jumps of 5 to 6 moves are
being
made with us  defense of lasker with the queen gambit well
with all due respect the value of the opening
there are some small subtleties there but
not for everyone from white and this is how I
expected hikaru to play for a win but
it looks like we won’t see any of this
because of course hikaru decided the
seatbelt  tighten what
we have here wait e5 castling white
has already done similar to young and 8 played
hikaru but cs  tati, I’m surprised, but
such a choice of opening, that is, somehow
hikaru, either in hot or cold, she’s a schedule
check, he played some kind of neck 6,
he’s a sim card, something like that, there are some
very sharp options, some
suspicious  even the date and then we
see they attack solidity, that is
, somehow katarna that can’t decide,
they took the stake on f6 went the rook goes
to t1 the last last, so to speak, the
problem remained to develop slate as
she has four hikaru puts by the way, maybe
he extinguishes their activity  tries to
show her four yes there somewhere aims
at and 3 touches your environment
if you are called cute and somewhere there
on it actually here although so
naturally white everything is very much too
under well, that is, the galaxy is very strong and the
austrian elephant is possible  it’s hard to play and not
get close yes, but for now,
it’s possible that the
liquid victim is hardly serious yes,
it’s almost possible that the anus we have three stents
have already gone with me words three fires, well,
you know, here they served what was yes  but
he’s also 5 bishop e2 to it four back
repeats the waste,
and there you are, and here you come out beretta
plays h2 h3 provoked his hikaru a little bit,
but by the way,
some kind of barcode did not pass the income at all
strange for rs4 feasts go what
you know  code h3
is here an invitation somewhere to this
elephant c8 in one step yes there our 3 was
donated some kind of language will run
back by the way h3 something not at all
like for 4 will have the villains one already
playing before some strange strange move of
power  so I wait and there is something
hikaru but here hikaru did something I also
like it in principle look he played h3
played c5
knight f3 d6 by the way firsa 4life 1 and 2
quality so wait after h3 so
cutter 4 just when combined is just a
huge advantage on  chirps in armor for
4 there is no way to protect the f-pawn but
it looks like some kind of 1 running blunders these are
our guys are already tired tired
chess players yes well from a positional point of
view it makes sense yes that is service 7 but
not with  tactic
dogul should have picked up something that is bad
note 4 in a second this move since I lila
no for 8 like this and now, well,
some kind of lull is waiting for us, but
look how Vasilisa immediately hit a
hole and he was hit and immediately he
got nervous  underestimated no longer typical, we
praised him that but he can’t
please in one move book doctor hikaru
offered him repetitions of moves, yes,
if you refuse repetition in order
to yawn just in a couple of moves, the
quality that hikaru for some reason decided
not to take away seems to me hikaru
just, somehow, I don’t even believe it, I don’t believe that
it’s yes, what are you if the sum of what is
earthly can yawn so simply yes yes
four rings 5 queen b4 not some kind of waste
back and forth we’
l come and it lo
ks like the hope for an attack is already somehow-  then it
dried when it fills up, it dried
up, nevertheless, the center opened up,
clinging to it, so wait 60 to 4
it returns, here again some
alarming bells as soon as there the
criticism
moves away from the kingside, he  about growing
us three plans
will help he is trying to create a sense of the
meeting I will beat the country in 5 quality and
wait for the offer 66 proves the
quality as if in 3 well so that everyone
took the crusher there is nothing to admit 8 to
exchange but this is probably grandfather stop
and immediately the horse  somewhere right away kun to 3 the same
thing will finish nothing on c8 disappointed
me together with I thought that they had already grown up for the second time
yes well it doesn’t work
candida looks but he takes his head sd8
so I let’s say hikaru plays well that is
such a technical position here just
completely in the style of Vasilis
technical technical but probably
equal keeps up to well, that is, usually what
happens to black pawn yes there it is a
distant potentially remote
passed passed one from and hurrying to and b subsidies to
advance killed them perfectly the square on d4 of an
ordinary cloth, that is, if you
change the queens  most often, white knights need to be
hoisted 4 and somehow it all levels
out, these two factors in the position will, of
course, strongly depend on if it
happens strongly  exchange of queens the one where the
remaining pieces with the exchange of queens
happens please yes here 4
swiped swiped on the same 4 I suggest
foam rubber switch swiped to d1
possession 4 right there 5 here Hikaru
yawned now if
you need to keep changing and lose to own up to 8
knight g5  date, look what move g5 is an
insidious psychological one, I
want to size the dimensions and now it’s like
exchanging after the move 5, well, there
follows a chance of up to 8 tons g5 but by the way, by the
way, he comes in and writes down 3 powerful yet
early, by the way, he can equally bring 4 played
gives if chess 8 king h7
let's go, let's stay 1 hour
,
yes, that is, white needs to create some kind of
contour game on the king,
and black, of course, now they will run, they will
take 3, they will run forward, he was
suspicious of this idea to
give up these two pawns, that is, even an
attack  it seems to me that it doesn’t compensate for the checkmate,
but karma doesn’t seem like the queens will go to the
defense perches 6 here doesn’t pick up
material, just perfection is
n’t 6  in the meantime, look where and in 1675
grandfathers bring everyone to 7, probably kun
544 doesn’t go for that, so that’s what he already
played instead of this, he played nakamura,
so let’s go back to everyone by the way, he’s
ready the most suggested switched, yes, the
video looks like we got bored  and immediately it
became very, very interesting meanwhile
Aronian defeated Fabiano Caruana like
this very quickly I don’t even know it looks like there is
also some group of yawns very sharply
very interesting to obama dior you karjakin
despite the lack of queens on the board
grischuk I don’t know it’s hard to say  well, in
general, eel, pike, is an extra pawn for which
the kettlebell probably has good compensation, but
won an das yours, I logra, you also have an
interesting position there, I would say that I’ll probably see it more pleasant,
well, let’s stay
until we stay with parkinson kamura,
because everything is equally divided as before
it somehow bends in the forest somehow, it
seems to me that everything is equal, but if
it really comes down to these pawn runs,
that is, even he can even three
pawns  against two they can 3
go slower because one two three times two three
so one two times two and ran the inscription
my hugs 4 already be 5 x
here as a rule if the king is on the
kingside yes it helps
to stop the pawns so White needs
no matter how many pawns  they don’t
have to play counterplay against the king,
create this tetta approximately like
this and deal with if gold and 5 went there,
but Hikaru has nothing to think about here,
you need to push forward what is called b4
la hold on to him already an extra pawn
you have a forest on which otherwise you might not
the
king and the queen se ne va sen
don’t really have time to go anywhere, you can still play la
hold the 8th step and put the rook
behind, put the rook behind, maybe but there the
king d700 check yes, besides the sim king d7
, everyone can play for himself until he has played clothes
eight  since the king of the north played, we
guessed it, yes, literally a few seconds
earlier than Hikaru made this move, that
is, his own 8 should be put behind to
slow down the movement of passers  black has it
there you know what it is I
think 316 you can get along with by the way you
accepted f4 gave the day a fat list and so that I’m
ready not anyhow 6 before if naturally
just calmly the king and everyone will go, that
is, they took the knight f3 the knight d4 here
it seems like a game  it ends it’s not clear how it’s
not visible how to stop the pawn and who
is the long option of course
they left well let’s make the first move
according to this variation
went b3 hikaru so it should go out
to do it looks like this game is like the
king h2 so far only two have played this is by the
way a waste of time  than in our
version in our version it’s pure
loss of time in 1655 can get and so
he didn’t play the rook 6 a 8 on 1 blundered this
idea here is a nice not so non
-trivial translation magic 6 mines on
occasion I don’t know why it is needed
but the main idea  in general, it can not be necessary, it is
not necessary to be distracted from the main
thing, so no, I somehow had the idea to give
check from 6 to lure to 3, then
I would have 6 when the knight tries to catch up with the
pawn  oh book 4, it might be
some kind of check, but it’s most likely not a necessary
subtlety, but a little white on, but already
kuni in the third, then return home
without bumping into anyone, we’ll try and then he
manages to block then he manages to
block
yes, you can start just become
well  then some other king king c7
there is a move so far
and maybe it seems to everyone at once it was turned on
instead of water 6g let's look at and
then everyone will also be only interested in
this tower here well then about so so
so there they have three inside went all the rook
6  step, so far, what’s going on with us is
kuni in 3 rook shisha king is 3 and again it’s
just asema, I can even dress
back now back to 6 by the way, the third
will lead like you 4 wait ka in
to 4 but that a4 is gone but it’s time to go
it's time to move 4 goes and white plays
rook b5 at this moment white plays the water
would be 5 a x well, that is, all the same, he tries to
pay off them inside like before the cube
so let's see if there
are some  Hikaru some opportunity
to prevent this from preventing it, well, yes,
it’s clear that the black one does not risk anything
here, the white ones of some kind retreated to them,
but where are the consequences of 60 to 3 behind the islands given to the
hodovka, went
gangotri went let him get dressed 6 but this
can’t  to be so there is still in such a
just in case so but here but didn’t he just give away
a pawn or what or or these two
never passed barking 5 6 of course of
course hikaru to play rooks 6 and that it
was just a gift of a pawn a very
strange person early to consume  already
why on the previous move of the Scythians I don’t
know yes but you know there is some kind of maybe by the
way no no it seemed poor
it was those king I 6 brilliant it seems
6 go on then we’ll just
go back 4 where was the next one
yes that is go like this  go rook b6 now
remember that the knight fights very badly with the
extreme pawn, it’s not a fact that
it won’t pass well, Poland, this stupidity is
such a bo3 beat first blundered the pawn
went to 6
now a strange decision but  I probably
promise anyway, still, the rook will
take the knight to b3 too now 6 to 1
king f3 and I had to take
not a single step to Patrick's rook, well, quickly now it will
destroy these remaining pawns, but most
likely it will not be possible to achieve a victory, as
it is possible to pump, you can even not  they will agree for the
night even if some such budget is
watts, I think it was trusted such a scale
holds 3 to 36 it is clear that it’s not for hikaru,
I think it will play such a combat
hikaru well, yes, I think that it will play a
role in 5 that the horse is through and one  there give
through h4 decides 4-6 knight knight brings
it out it can be another
longest game yes because here you are
here on hikaru can try
there he has 50 moves to take the
lie or force her to move the rush has
advanced the description itself  then
another 50s without any yes without any
but you know maybe a draw will be just
because now the
pawn will reach somewhere and our electronic board does not have time
for the players I'm here
let's settle  we look at maxim bozhye logrov
lost ananda
slowed down inside defeat padre
generation of defeat in a row as soon as
maxim was struck yes i.e. and he suffered
three defeats in a row his dinner a point is
bypassed by levon
aronian or he is approaching very close she is
not quite two defeats of the previous one he
nevertheless managed to happen a miracle  to escape
yes so so so there we return until we
return
let's look at the diesel without a board
here there is no big sense
in all these moves here, that is,
they just wait until they wait for a yawn, by the
way, almost they again, isn't there a
little hikaru here b7 rook there  now
the last one will be liquidated, the fifth one
defended yes, it’s true that the king and five are not yet possible,
well, it’s a question could at least 4 it’s a
matter of time
it will take the delay, and then, as
they say, the fortune teller don’t go a pawn, it will take the
water and 2 so what other results do we have
draw eels  pike and givi defeated the Aronians and let us
remind you that Karjakin is also fighting against the
Mamedyars, and there they also look like a draw
most likely though no no there is something
like an hour rather ken karjakin wins
snags it seems to be winning so
no no no one agreed there that
adele yawned vs forests
yawned it went well yawned your face yawned
adele so how did it all end
before hikaru won  this one is
unbelievable, but it’s really about the
hole before they made a hole like that in your
forest, that is, as soon as you suffered the first
defeat, you immediately suffered the second
everything got confused everything got confused wins the
Aronian pocket and
we already have all the neighbors which after the
first day everything is completely not
obvious to us  come on,
let's probably have a table let me
remind you of this dish, let me remind you that sergey
karyakin won in the last round an incredible
scoring round 1 the only draw for
grischuk as up to 4m scoring games 4
scoring games out of 5 pleased
us in the end maybe we can do something
even more  and see if
we have if we have a table it would
certainly be interesting to look at  the situation,
well, let's, let's maybe some
kind of game against some guys, in
fact, in fact, Aronian lost, he was
wounded, he won against Karl, well,
I don’t understand this at all, by the way,
Aronian’s table shows Duck and we somehow completely forgot that
karyakin we have a karyakin yes he also
wins and now the gap of thought is only
one and a half points for his sarochka then all the time
nothing just one and a half points remains the
gap nemox
game by the way and nakamura by the way still
fights up to 18 in your forest I
will now try to tell you who scored how many
points  today this is an
interesting moment, because, according to my
version, today we are the winner of this tournament,
so if we think it looks like a piece of
karjakin, damn it,
yes, or Zhenya is incorrect, by the way, yes,
rather, for now now,
literally such small calculations, and
now we will figure it out, that is, on the very
In fact, she greatly improved her situation,
but Karyakina correctly, by the way,
won three in a row
Bulo Grava of the Crown Mamedyarov Karyak  ying
won three in a row three in a row to the finish line
well, this is already this is already very
very decent yes this is already very decent
well yes ananko early niches and briskly not really
so not at all bad things look like
Fabiano Caruana are going Pomeroy Rovd they didn’t flash
mamedyarov didn’t flash frankly the
rain frame didn’t flash he stopped the
leader actually but the vixen
actually stopped the leaders by the decree of the forest
so a fly in the ointment yes yes yes yes, that’s how we are,
according to my calculations, here, as they say on the
knee, today’s blitz tournament was
won by karjakin with a score of 6 half
out of 9
and five and a half out of nine today
levon aronian scored
an impressive result but here
again sergey he will have to repeat
this feat to score 6 points
tomorrow in order to still catch up with you
face today managed to reduce one and a half
points but I think you  terribly dissatisfied
after all, such two zeros at the finish line
skip this lesson
rook rook will not lose it hurts it hurts
it hurts and then there’s another moment t  which
tomorrow, two hours earlier to start the chairs, I
remind you, yes, that is, it will hurt us to
wake up, it will be painful to
wake up, no, but I just need to
understand something and here is a finished blitz tournament,
some distance and a person loses
two games after that he has no chance
to win back  today, yes, that is, until it
goes on a break with these sensations
of some kind of trembling in my hands, yes, I
lost 2 if there was one more round and even a
draw the game ended but somehow
calmed down somehow came all my life
continues until now  so two defeats and
you were sent for a break, I don’t know
how stable yes, the psyche is there in
the face as far as he can cope, but
in general this is such a blow that is not
clear enough, know the reason for the condition,
let’s see how well he manages
to cope and it looks like a little logger has
also entered  drip, but as soon as he
got the first hole, he could get flour 3 0 by the
way yes yes yes, that is, he was
amnestied there until, however, in general, that
is, very good  osho played maxim the first
half of this blitz and then
something really fell apart, so
what do we propose to check
all the same how Aronian won against
the pocket maybe this is the last
game that we will be able to watch
again fabian continues to unsuccessfully
test the sicilian it is still possible to return
grischuk to  I lost more beautifully on the caliper and
I don’t know how beautifully, but I also
lost and lost wider than Aronyan,
he lost for a worm of ricon and lost in Russian
and all the shootings turned out to give
aku our sins from the crown 20 to
just in case and so weakly 4 castling is
short, that is, again here with  black plays the same idea to
spoil the hairstyle take
on the zither up to up to 7 to 6 so it was always unclear to me
whether it was worth voluntarily
15 3 because he immediately appeared on
the 3rd is the motive before reaching 3 and 5 and
that's all or something  yes, that is, and was left
without quality, well, how is everything, well, that is, all the
same, there is compensation for this, yes,
positional here it looks like over there, but
this Livonian piece  the pupils started bypassing the
meowing plan again, yes, it’s
pretty, yes, that is, one turns out to
capture the capture of the queen 5 the bishop b7 follows
while calmly and on the water and 7
is in 80 shahan yes there the king the
king goes there it doesn’t matter where the queen d8
also bit the rook  in the end,
therefore, they again we own played, but
here you still got a blow on the bass
path, you can tell that for the horse it was necessary to
walk now, by the way, fire and again
it’s not clear, but it’s essentially by the way, but not
everything is so simple by the way for whites, so
wait for the windows on the 6th  already there, anyway,
some kind of fishing rods at the base,
winter took it, took the check, it’s necessary 6 would own one
good there, not to something, but it’s married as
possible and it’s not clear by the way, by the way, something
like that can be fierce 86 prada candy
Friday overlap but  why we won’t
speculate here anymore, it’s not clear here, rather,
well, in this particular position it
doesn’t seem to work, so perhaps Fabian also blundered towards
the winter with the moves of the rook a7, that is, in
any case, the cavalry 6 but apparently warmed up
b6  play to drive the knight back
and then already there, quite comfortably, I
got an envelope
bassem such a ball owning one bishop b5 rook
one yes, that is, take this if now the
full size is on the pool here am c dm d7
c 1 .  thanks, he doesn’t plan to leave, and here
’s the same bullet from the rig to, that is,
Fabian, yes, he exchanged early in the center
and from the same bullet 3-6 enters to
beat her here to finally
emphasize the water hits b5 and just gave up,
that is, he began to cry out to  at least
everything is possible for me even apparently by recalculating the queen 6 by 7,
it seems that the author himself after 6 is even more
disgusting and and just on this pin
now we will lose something else, that is, or
we need to play the rook 6 before the connection and change,
but these are already loaded passers and  it’s
clear that there are no chances, in
general, yes, something Fabian was too clever here in
some protracted struggle, Karjakin Mamedyarov won,
I think we won’t go
back to this, and so, well, we
had a rapid tournament
two days before, in which we won
we know you forests from today in one day
a blitz tournament was held in which
karjakin won, in fact, these are all the steps of
one tournament in lebanon tomorrow there will be the
final last round 9 more rounds
each will play with each  yes, that is, it
will actually be a repetition of today's
tournament with the reverse color, once again
we remind you that Yaroslav worked
sideways and Evgeny Miroshnichenko
and once again we remind you that tomorrow all this
chess action will begin two hours
earlier please don't miss if we
wake up we will try to wake up and
what  and we wish you all the best thanks
for watching us today until tomorrow
[music]